mathilde francou est avec nous bonjour
mathilde on va voir les événements à ne
pas manquer cet été sur le territoire
des yvelines il est tout beau il est
tout neuf cet été les yvelinois peuvent
monter à bord d'un nouveau tramway c'est
le thé 13 exactement grégory inauguré
officiellement début juillet le nouveau
tram t 13 relie saint cyr l'école à
saint germain les en 30 minutes sa
spécificité il roule à 100 km/heure sur
certaines portions comme un train puis
ralentit à 30 km heure en ville et passe
en mode tramway voici les propos
recueillis par julien leroy lors de
l'inauguration
tout à l'heure je voyais un jeune homme
qui me disaient qu'ils habitaient mareil
marly et qu'il avait un bus toutes les
heures quant à eux leur agrément et
oncle en dix minutes donc vous imaginez
si la pollution en moi c'est la qualité
de vie en plus et c'est j'allais dire la
qualité de vie de la grande ville dans
un département qui est beaucoup plus
rural qu'urbain l'inauguration a été
perturbée par des riverains qui ont
manifesté contre les nuisances sonores
provoquées par le thé 13ème qu'à propos
de ce chantier qui est désormais
terminée puisqu'il est effective ce tte
13 dans les yvelines alors y'a d'autres
chantiers à venir eux cet été un
département des yvelines profitent de
cette période estivale pour réaliser des
travaux sur ces routes au total 69
chantier dans 70 communes des yvelines
sont prévues cet été sécurisation
modernisation aménagements le chantier
phare de cet été le pont de la 2e
division blindée entre maisons laffitte
et sartrouville sur la rd 308 attention
ces travaux peuvent perturber vos
trajets retrouvez la liste complète des
chantiers sur le site du département
plusieurs communes elles lancent leur
opération d'été plein d'animations à
prévoir jeux sorties ateliers c'est
partout et c'est pour tous les goûts
d'ailleurs oui grégory c'est le retour
d'été en sable par exemple à montigny le
bretonneux pour les trappistes cet été
le programme est riche également avec
des semaines à thème comme les jeux
olympiques ou encore koh lanta les
grandes villes du département comme les
petites communes proposent des
animations alors n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet de votre
ville pour avoir toutes les informations
soixante dix huit secondes de projection
de séances de cinéma qui seront
proposées dans le cadre de l'opération
les yvelines font leur cinéma qui est de
retour 78 séances sont proposées dans
soixante dix huit communes des yvelines
tu étais à partir du 19 août jusqu'au 17
septembre se succéderont des dessins
animés des comédies des films
d'aventurés j'en passe le tout en plein
air et gratuitement pour connaître les
lieux de projection et le programme
rendez vous sur yvelines a tiré info.fr
la commanderie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fait aussi 7e
art cet été effectivement tous les
jeudis jusqu'au 25 août les visiteurs
pourront découvrir ou redécouvrir un
film sous un ciel étoilé au programme
sos fantômes l'appel de la forêt ou
encore l'animé le château ambulant là
encore c'est totalement gratuit plus
d'informations sur le site de la
commanderie s'entend de la musique quel
style nicolau mikaël
[Musique]
tam départ un peu plus pop mais je mets
le rap aussi bon j'aurais pu terminer ou
nicolas vous ça fait la transition
transition et les pros en termine en
musique
après le cinéma après tout toutes ces
bonnes choses de la musique avec le
festival électrique par qui sera aussi
de retour cet été à la fin de tout ça
pour même si ce n'est pas mon style de
prédilection et bien deux jours entiers
de musique électro espaces et sur cinq
scènes au sein de l'île des
impressionnistes à chatou avec une
cinquantaine d'artistes dont bakker matt
martin solveig mr oizo ou encore the
boys il y en a pour tous les goûts
l'électrique parc se déroulera les 3 et
4 septembre